[Music]
my name
welcome to new heights playa let me
share this one it's called the small
holes no I have Roz I have a lot of
problems talking lately I don't know
what's the matter with me I played the
other small hearts the small horse oh it
has an intro like it yes with the epic
music not really
it has pro in it so it's gotta be real
audition if you know what I mean I don't
know what I just said but I said it I
don't know that's a pony he's angry for
whatever reason you don't want to mess
with angry Pony senses something I heard
about
[Applause]
[Music]
ha
what what game was I playing again oh
yes ok this makes total sense
yes but why did I think of this before
wait Stan Van is that you swine is
awkward okay I am somehow at the volcano
of course
[Music]
I'm excited before the hell
okay that's a bunch of anime characters
traveling
[Music]
oh look at oh wow what are you doing go
chief Wiggum tell us what happened
don't punch me why what the hell this is
amnesia what all right
I like this this is much better whenever
I'm used to
hello good day to you sir trust a noble
warrior I can hear with my ears all
right I am going like a bus oh you have
to go like this I think yes all right
these sand things are huge
this is that girls titties I'm just
kidding but one piece I think is called
I never really followed it hey remember
me I will reign the mavericks hidden
what I'm in the sand in front of me is
that fire ouch ha I know what else no no
all right let's check out this little
okay nothing over here this is this is
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's all I'm gonna
say about that this is some disturbing
oh that's a pony
hello party how you doing carny
come here Bodie I thought you're doing
breakdancing talk to me
take me with you I want to live in the
cave here there I just pick up Twilight
it's a pony what else
well of course so let's go to this cave
cuz she wants to live there I mean it
makes sense the pony wants to live in a
cave that looks and I would prefer to
stay out there but okay fine let's go in
here water hey I hope the curry cave is
as cozy as the other things cuz
otherwise I'm in trouble big trouble
super trouble if you know what I mean
yeah yeah are you all right why is it
locked in the Pony unlock it
oh the pony unlocked well whatta [ __ ]
all right lighten up man that I am
what are you doing whoo and all put a
man turn it back in okay you're doing
that much in give me the ladder nod man
damn you tricked me my team why are you
sleeping naked man team are to hell they
are dancing pony McDonough's I always
wanted to see McDonald's in Anisha my
life is now complete
oh I can pick that up product placement
don't show it take up take the burger
alright payday I am a baguette God hate
me I would be our best friend forever
that sounds fantastic
what Dragonball now and a poo from a
lledon what the [ __ ] is going on hey
boss what are you doing looking fancy
barrels oh is this subtle that right no
I don't even know how that [ __ ] can I
dance with you alright I'm dancing with
my burger just try to blend in here yeah
yeah look at that monkey finger slapping
it slap my burger monkey slap it good
don't make him slap mades my only
weakness ha I found your only way kid
monkeys slapping you there you go go
there forever
All Right see you later I always be
going over here even a posar it's open
paddy what
did the door just call me a fatty Walker
Haley said [ __ ] it's the Apple over here
it's a power source maybe a veggie thigh
knows something about it all right let's
about the power lever all right I get it
Wow but em punch that's hilarious
hilarious
are you Vegeta I guess it's the one in
the middle if I know correctly oh why am
i staring at his class stop step what Oh
No 9000 what Vegeta are you hugging me
Bonita he likes it did you slap the
burger all right let me go over here
very good all right
I still need an apple listen that
delightful let's go up again nice nice
oh no what the hell no no no no not any
time take about it
stop this [ __ ] right now
don't slap my burger only I pull out the
bun oh I got the Apple give it an apples
no it's too fat
all right I'm throwing it down there
there we go that's how you throw an
apple [ __ ] and then we take them
chicken McNuggets taking the shitty - oh
you want the chicken that's my chicken
my luggage back up come in eat there for
me what po breakdancing time all right
lovely party I'm sorry but it's late get
around chicken mcnuggets come here
you're coming with me look like a poo
not a poo ah what a day this is some
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's all I gotta say about
it I like it said a lot of things oh no
lovely whoa what the hell who are you
over there and they and nest that's a
lock time what about this huh
whoa
[Music]
I'm sorry I'm alright I did not like
that alright let's go let's go see you
later alligator
alright lovely oh it's party time in
here that's locked I have the key no
that's not - that makes no sense
why would they all be locked however
they place does oh maybe this one is
open yes hallelujah
whoa what do you do I don't rusty I
don't care how tall you are
let me jump off in it oh I'm not humping
I'm just trying to do a bucket bucket
bucket bucket where's the pan oh he
would start this mess out oh maybe I
should read this fire lightning
my name is Gulliver's Johnny I have some
things that you can bear why is every
bear everywhere
and I've got the biggest beam you've
ever seen a strange guy in a cloak came
and said got some good things on staler
stranger he sold me a cage I thought a
cage for what I said now I can't
continue this later my head the father
the Halloween's Aram's gum was my by my
side he was searching for a horse and
some guy called sky him [ __ ] but I don't
know what that means
because I am Japanese he left for some
unknown reasons by and that's still a
better love story than the Twilight oh
oh no stop saying hello
alright I'm sick of this [ __ ] whoa Wow
don't eat my face I prefer my fission
our détente
don't look at me boy oh it's coming
after me ah oh no this is not good
use the key all right see you later okay
whoever you are
mystery man let's go in here now oh we
still have the key not bad though
all right let's fire this woman all
right I like about well let's say Alice
[ __ ] whoa holy [ __ ] that man is riding a
pony his name is holy LP then I suddenly
found the house
all right you found a house and then
what's the student super arrow tisha
care what mosquito employer what a nice
dish yes the homies weapon hacked no oh
what sonic shot the thingy what [ __ ] I
agree right the [ __ ] we kissed it a book
why thank you
that solves everything truce cherish to
you too
now ride that pony alright I picked up
oh it was a crate big enough to
transport a small house the Halloween
all right fine I'll just continue this
journey then nope I can't a not allowed
to journey forward whoa Martin whoa oh
but dad what the hell are you doing my
kid Martini's on a fricking Farooqi
mother [ __ ] he's on some serious [ __ ] I
told him to lay off the cocaine but damn
boy Martin I did seriously now for this
nonsense
whoa whoa oh oh nothing stop this [ __ ]
button I didn't do anything honey stop
stop running
stop it southern stop it stop it stop it
stop it stop it let's go over here
silly monkey crazy
all right let's continue yeah oh no
right right
why oh no oh no this is not our way I
wanted things to end what is this why do
I go oh no oh I just jump up here all
right what the hell what about what to
do here oh no it's the hemorrhoid oh no
oh oh the door [ __ ] closed and it's
scared that penis out of me you're down
close in front of me like that
pony pony [ __ ] off take this crate and
eat it don't come near me sorry pony all
right it's this I forgot to read it
that's what you get I throw that
hemorrhoid on you oh it sounds like she
likes it actually let's try it one more
time all right and now we catch you come
here pick at you
can we pick at you oh you like that
don't you you little [ __ ] take a job
take a joke come here I dare you Pikachu
Lacey where do you go where is it oh
there you are
holy [ __ ] Oh what
all right are you crying oh I feel so
bad for you doing what some Latin Adam
oh wait I took it finally find the
bigger treasure than anyone can imagine
but what will come are you safe now
found out to play the small [ __ ] they
escaped alright so that was probably the
most [ __ ] up custom story well
guarantee Lee the most [ __ ] up cuts
and story I ever played all right not
bad not bad at all sir I hope you
enjoyed it I don't know I don't even
know what to say to that about that
anything I'm just happy but DITA was in
there and I get the stares crouched I
get the names mixed up because I didn't
really watch dragon ball we didn't have
it aired in Sweden it's not my fault
don't judge me anyway like your favorite
if you enjoyed subscribe to come abroad
today and I'll see you next episode
thanks I only just recently stopped
complaining it's not a big deal all you
did was I'm not gonna hold to get raped
by a policeman that's what you get